good shot Santa going down that was
distance right there thanks is that your
last shot you hit it on second second
huh yeah I was out there that was a good
reach I felt like that was gonna happen
I wasn't quite sure and then oh yeah you
know when it starts going down it's a
good feeling that's a good boy that's a
good boy some dogs they'll get Bubba
Goose they might get a little
intimidated because they're so big right
it doesn't seem to back down so he's
loving it out here right now
we just want to make sure to capitalize
on this time and get as many birds as we
can
two guns is better than one yep two of
us shooting double our chances I'm done
hunting when our freezers are full so
we're gonna get it done and get as many
geese as we can
the journey today
feels good to reach the goal you know
because the river through pretty much
everything it could at me
food's kind of just Frozen at this point
you know you always want things to just
work perfectly and you end up having to
go
you hell and high water but I'm super
grateful ah it feels nice
so at this point I gotta get this canoe
hung up tie it up high into one of these
trees
come back in early fall
bring the rifle bring Java
foreign
and we just float down the river
[Music]
I'm frustrated can't find this buoy
where's that damn thing at it should be
like right in here
[Music]
I'm just gonna put a weight on here and
the bottom of it drag this thing around
if I can go across the ways to the
current maybe we can hook onto the line
if that buoy is like 10 feet under
thank you
[Music]
the good thing about it is it hooks made
out of wood bone and Spruce root we
harvested the material to make these
hooks from nature they went back to
Nature
well let's pull that roping and head
back
Alaska's tough
Alaska took my halibut hook Alaska has
taken some of my friends
but Alaska has also given us everything
that we possibly need to thrive and
survive here
it's an amazing place but you've got to
treat it with respect
well I think it's done Jeff
this is what we live for that's the
beauty
there it is
hearing Birds better make that quick
buddy
hello
we'll grab our goose and bring it into
the blind with us so we can snack on it
while we're hunting let's get in there
all right
we're secure when we have Birds heading
to the freezer just a great time to be
around a campfire a little bit do some
hunting at the same time we enjoy eating
what we're shooting
[Music]
thank you